I'll show them the power of the darkness
no one will stand in our way I will
finish what you started
wobble where do you come from oh wow
classified really
me too we can upload them with
we need a pilot we could one
come on baby don't let me down
this one will squad take my lead
we will crush resistance one super roll
you must face them
fight them all of us what
you
we got a lot of company
hey youtubers is charlie so there's some
new Star Wars footage probably like the
last really big trailer we're going to
get before the actual movie which is
totally coming next week who can believe
that we are getting this movie next week
it's going to be so awesome the real
surprise is just like how many new shots
are in this trailer like we get more
shots of that green planet that maz
kanata's pirate bases on we get another
shot of Han Solo doing a line from the
original trilogy come on baby don't let
me down wheeler the bb-8 origin is
classified mine too why would raise
origin be classified the way they teach
her backstory is that she's kind of
grown up on her unless she's kind of
raised herself learn to survive and how
she became a scavenger I'm kind of
thinking of her is like the Luke
Skywalker character- uncle Owen and aunt
Beru you know just because a lot of the
way she dresses and a lot of aspects for
backstory and a lot of things that I
think about her character that then you
know maybe potentially spoilery so I
won't mention here but I think we all
have ideas about certain characters like
the new characters being related to
classic trilogy characters I think that
she is definitely in that vein so mark
hamill said this really interesting
thing at comic-con raised like
everything's the same but it's different
it's amazing so I think they've split a
lot of backstory traits and little
aspects about characters from the class
of trilogy and giving them to the new
characters so like look at finn's
character he starts out in the empire
but he has this crisis of conscience
same thing that happened to han Solo at
least in the expanded universe now
they're doing a new han solo movie but
the way they're pitching it it sounds
like it's going to be Han Solo in his
20s so we might actually get to see him
when he quits the Empire if you don't
know that story about Han Solo the
Empire rounded up a lot of the Wookiee
race just because they were such great
workers and made them construct the
first Death Star so during that period
Han Solo was part of the Empire it just
happened to be in proximity to this wiki
uprising so his commanding officer
ordered him to kill this group of
wookies but he instead chose to rescue
them one of those bookies just happened
to be Chewbacca so to bacchus wore his
life debt to han Solo and then they went
off had their adventures in the rest is
history so I think what's happening with
the fing character know a lot of this
footage is like he's getting aspects of
the Anakin backstory where he kills a
bunch of people like the Tusken Raiders
that Anakin killed but has the Han Solo
crisis of conscience instead of like
anakin and like burying it deep down
inside like oh my god i can't do this
anymore what am I supposed
do with my life I'm not supposed to be
doing this but I have absolutely no idea
what I'm doing which is when it sounds
like he runs into the Ray character gets
swept up in this big large Galactic
conflict it does seem like we know a lot
more about the fin character than we
know about the Ray character
particularly her backstory like it's
supposed to be really mysterious which
is why I think it's going to be pretty
spectacular there have been a couple
spoilery toys that like it had some
spoilery images on them so I'm not going
to talk about them here but suffice to
say there'll be a couple ray moments
that will make you throw up in the
theater from excitement that is really
what I'm excited for like you know even
if you know a lot about Star Wars I
still feel like they're going to be some
really big surprises in this film look
we actually get a longer voiceover from
Supreme Leader Snoke we're finally going
to crush the resistance and it actually
sounds a little bit more like Andy
Serkis like you can actually hear him
bleeding through a little bit the funny
thing is is when the first trailer
dropped a lot of people were like is
that Benedict Cumberbatch doing his
convoys from star trek into darkness and
speaking of which if you didn't hear me
mention it earlier this week they are
attaching the star trek 3 trailer to
star wars in the theater so I'm not sure
what its gonna drop next week but
sometime next week you will have new
star trek to watch with a very awesome
Idris Elba villain no idea who he's
playing but it is going to be so much
fun he's such an awesome actor what's
going to happen next week with my Star
Wars videos is I'll do a couple bonus
videos before the movie and then after
the movie drops i'll do a non-spoilery
review then I'll do a separate spoilery
review just because a couple people are
gonna wait a couple days to watch the
movie so be sure to subscribe to get
everything I'll do a couple star
wars-themed giveaways so actually i'll
go ahead and start one right now all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video we'll
just say to imax tickets again everybody
seems to like that give away everybody
likes imax tickets there are a couple
different formats that Star Wars is
going to screen it but if you have a
chance to see it in true imax like the
true big you know 70 millimeter imax i
would encourage you to go to that format
i have some new Doctor Strange some new
captain america civil war that i'll try
and post later tonight well I guess wait
for that you can click here for all my
other Star Wars Episode 7 videos and you
can click here for my captain america
civil war trailer thank you so much for
watching everybody let's have fun i'll
see you guys tonight me me me me me
you